It's been kind of a heartbreaking day on the ranch today.
Mother Goose, who had just successfully,
you know, hatched her first Gosselin.
And she's been with us for a long time.
Um, we aren't sure what happened,
but she was found, um,
passed away on her nest this morning.
You know,
she still had a clutch of eggs that she was religiously sitting on,
trying to get more than one costly in the hatch.
And we think she just overworked herself.
You know, she'd sit on that nest for most of the day,
would get up to eat a little bit,
drink a little bit,
but she just.
That's what we think.
We don't really know.
There's no evidence of blood
or something attacked her or foul play or anything like that.
Um, just a really sad deal.
So we found her.
There's papa goose,
and the gosling is doing really well.
He's here protecting mama goose.
But as you can see,
she's.
She passed away right on her nest,
where she had been sitting for the better part of,
you know, the last month.
It's really sad.